how did your father die from witchcraft
we did a ritual in the entrance of the
house we were speaking in tongues and
after the a a demon came and the main
witch she just got possessed and she
started to speak and this wit look at my
mom and told my mom like someone in your
family is going to die in one week so I
look at my mom and I told her let's I
don't want to know because I was so
suicidal that I didn't want to know one
week later so by this point I was with
this H which my mom called us at like 4:
in the morning 4 5 and she said you have
to come home quick I enter the house and
when I entered the house I felt this
heavy atmosphere it's like someone put a
cloth on me I run outside and I have the
feeling to check next to the storage
that we had close to the house and when
I pushed my dad committed suicide and he
was hanging there and when I saw it for
me that was the moment where my my whole
existence just collapsed